but for Google the scariest moment is
the interface is disrupted where people
don't have to like actually interact
with links in the way they do today and
that's something that Larry cannot just
go and change immediately because he is
running a public company that has
billions of dollars in market cap and
like constantly answerable to Wall
Street expectations and Wall Street just
wants them to increase that advertising
Revenue right but this is disruptive to
that so hence why an opportunity exists
for a new startup like
ours all right guys bang bang uh I
thought a great place to start this
conversation would be uh on Twitter you
shared this clip of Larry pagee talking
about the dream search engine and kind
of what he hoped Google would become
when you listen to his description it
sounds like he's describing perplexity
much more than he's describing what
Google has become talk a little bit
about maybe the evolution of these
search engines and why is perplexity
able to build something that's much more
closer to even the founders of of
Google's vision for the perfect search
engine yeah so I mean I'm a big fan of
Larry Page
and most people you would talk to about
Larry would always just say the guy was
living in the future like he's always
Imagining the future many years before
it happens
and why this moment has arrived much
later than he envisioned is because um
first of all his vision was the ultimate
version of Google artificial
intelligence uh and if you have an AI it
would exactly understand what you're
asking and just directly give you the
answer to it instead of you having to
open links that that's basically the
video that I shared and
um so why is it that like he couldn't do
it and we are doing it I think it's not
due to lack of technology that he
couldn't do it obviously you know he's
no longer running the
company um and and Google has a b big
business model to protect today which is
based on how many people view link and
how many people click on a link they
basically optimize their frontend so
much that the entire company's Destiny
relies on that 10 BL link user interface
it's one of those rare Mo things you
know most trillion dollar companies have
divested their bets a lot like for
example Microsoft if there is a new
LinkedIn competitor it's not a big deal
they have like a lot of money from Azure
they a lot of money from Gam they a lot
of money from operating systems and
windows um similarly to Apple like you
can maybe argue iPhone is the most
important thing but the whole end to end
packaging of the ecosystem is so strong
that um it's very hard for anyone to
imagine taking them all but for Google
the the the the scariest moment is the
interface is disrupted where people
don't have to like actually interact
with links in the way they do today
because and that's something that Larry
cannot just go and change immediately
because he uh is running a public
company that has trillions of dollars in
market cap and like constantly
answerable to Wall Street expectations
and Wall Street just wants them to
increase that advertising Revenue right
but this is disruptive to that so hence
why an opportunity exists for a new
startup like ours which can go back to
the Whiteboard empty whiteboard think
from scratch versus having a lot of
whiteboards with lots of equations and
trying to see which variable to change
to adjust that's that's Google and and
um that's like a classic innovator
dilemma there and like we are benefiting
from that now one of the things inside
of your interface that I think a lot of
people immediately notice is I ask a
question I get the answer I don't get
links I get the answer but there's also
citations and I can kind of go to the
original Source I can go deeper into
that answer if I would like to talk
about maybe the the philosophy as to why
to present even though you can give the
answer to still give the source material
um and the links for allowing that
exploration into these answers yeah so
our philosophy has always been give the
power to the user as much as possible
now have an opinion about the product
like don't try to do something like you
put a summary at the top and you have
the 10 Blue Links at the bottom and I
give you both that's sort of like the
Google UI today um you know have a clear
opinion that hey like link shouldn't be
a prominent part of the real state of
the product anymore it should be answers
and it should be conversations it should
be ability to dig deeper and ask
follow-ups but make sure the user can
still go and find out the truth if they
want to in case you got it wrong because
these AIS are still not accurate enough
for you to just blindly believe what
they say they still make mistakes like
maybe 80 80 to 90% of the answer is
accurate but like maybe there's one
sentence there that's inaccurate so even
if the user believes something is like
not likely to be true then they can
still go and check the source and read
for themselves until AIS get to a point
where they're like super accurate right
um I always believe like there's an
idealistic way of thinking about things
which is like the ultimate version of AI
will not even require you to type in
stuff you'll just exactly know what you
want in your head and like you don't
even have to ask that's all in the
future but and part of product
engineering is to give some elements of
the future today with hacks right 10
buildings was a hack to get you to the
answer now uh answers with sources and
citations is another hack now five years
from now maybe you're like I you know
what I I hardly see myself clicking The
Source like it's it's dramatically
dropped I'm just reading your answer
your AI is like one in a thousand times
inaccurate I don't care right and and
then at that point you're just going to
talk to it like a human you don't even
have to type you can just have an
airpods and you can just walk around and
ask questions right so um I believe like
this is the right you interface today to
make a paradigm shift and that's why we
went for it and also another reason we
did it is like I I come from an academic
background another of my co-founder also
comes from an academic background and
the first thing you're taught in
Academia when when you're writing a
research paper is like always never
write anything in the paper that you
cannot actually attribute a source from
a peer reviewed article uh and and we
took that philosophy what if an chatbot
was designed with this rule that
everything it says has to come from the
web fundamental difference from chat GPT
chat GPT can say whatever it wants
perplexity can only say what exists on
the web and it also has to attribute
what it says in every single sentence to
a particular Source it's taking from and
um so that that's that's part of like
our our background that's you know going
into the product too talk to me about
the future you just described walking
the airpods on and just asking questions
and getting answers is that what you
think is kind of the end state of this
Innovation or or you know maybe it's 10
15 20 years away but like where is this
all headed and how far into the future
do you see right
now
um I would say we can create a really
good voice too experience in an couple
of years maybe I'm even overestimating
that out uh
timeline
but for you to like not even look at a
computer or a phone will take a while
like for example if an answer is
actually detail you don't want it to be
read out to you right like it's kind of
laborious to hear the whole
thing um so you want it to be visually
rendered and then the AI has to know
exactly when
to when to render things when to just
speak it out and that depends on like
you know it should already know to what
extent you're interested in without you
having to prompt engineer it so those
are the kind of
like truly understanding your intent is
going to take a while the models have to
be really smart and also be able to run
on device as much as possible to
minimize computer overload so these are
all like you know engineering details
it'll take a while to figure out um I
believe that we uh if we have glasses
not just airpods the visual rendering
part will also like kind of be taken
care of we can just project things out
and read it for us if we wanted to and
that means like our interaction with uh
Computing is obviously going to change
to new form factors glasses airpods and
more humanlike interactions with how we
you know interact with fellow humans um
and and whenever we still doing work
like let's say we are actually doing
work writing writing something uh
creating something we'll still go back
to our computer and like you'll still
work on it uh but it'll feel more like
you want to work rather than you have to
work that that that sort of the future I
think we are going towards explain that
a little bit further in terms of uh
there's a lot of fear I think of AI
taking jobs and kind of what's everyone
going to do I usually point back to at
one point it was like 98% of people in
North America were farmers now it's less
than 2% right and so we found other
things to do other work to do um but
you're talking about a world where maybe
we work because we want to not because
we have to how do we get there and what
is that world
like so I think today there's a lot of
jobs that just require you to manually
do a lot of
things um for example there are still
jobs you won't believe this but there
are still jobs that just take physical
uh records of people's application forms
and trying to digitize that uh there are
still jobs that try to like edit any
mistakes in someone else's article
there are still jobs that um you know
like do Brute Force um stitching
together pipes of different apis because
someone else doesn't want to do those
Integrations translating code from one
language to another because a company's
moving Frameworks these are all like
super boring but the only way to solve
them today is like dump it on an agency
that'll hire a bunch of people and then
they'll do this for you and give it back
to you now we we're not going to enter a
world where that agency fully deprecated
but if that agency had 100 people now
instead it can actually have five to 10
people and have 80% of the work done by
an
AI so does that mean 90 people are
losing their jobs yes you know the the
10 people will be retained and these are
the 10 who are actually really good at
it like they can quickly look at the
mistakes and identify mistakes and point
out so that naturally leads to the
conclusion that those are are going to
retain their jobs are those who Embrace
AIS have a knack of where they go wrong
and right keep up to the latest up toate
speed whatever the latest Cutting Edge
AIS are and have really good judgment
human judgment is going to be more
valuable than human labor and creation
like it's it's it's little bit hard to
um internalize this because we always of
the opinion that we are the most
creative people on the Planet but we we
it's sort of what Rick ruin says you
need to have incredibly good judgment
and the actual process of creation like
knowing which tools to use you know like
which instruments to use like which
software to use all that is going to be
like not super valuable anymore it's
more like can you look at the end output
and say like what's actually going wrong
there and then give that as feedback to
an AI or a computer that you're
interacting with and make good use of it
to be able to get the same um end output
much faster than was possible before and
people are going to employ you probably
they're going to pay you even
more than what you got paid earlier but
people are going to employ fewer people
and and and that's going to take a while
for the population to
internalize but that's guaranteed to
happen talk about the constraints to
getting there obviously Hardware is is a
constraint uh some of the sophistication
and accuracy of these models is a
constraint um but maybe we can start
with the hardware first there's really
two sides to the hardware there's the
consumer interface which you're talking
about whether it's glasses or or other
types of devices but also these models
run on Hardware right and we've seen
Nvidia and many of these other companies
uh that are even tangentially related to
Hardware do very well in terms of
investor returns so how do you see the
constraints on that Hardware side in
terms of where this uh these llms and
software is running and then on the
consumer side it sounds like that's a
couple of years away still this episode
episod is brought to you by bet online
do you like making a profit from sports
betting well set yourself up to take
home the most profit possible using
crypto to fund your sports betting
casino and poker account at
betonline.ag you can avoid costly
transaction fees get your payouts
lightning fast and do it all securely
and anonymously with the highest deposit
and withdrawal limits in the industry if
you want to get in on the action do it
the smart way with crypto at
betonline.ag head to the website sign up
with promo code pomp 100 to get 100%
bonus on your crypto deposit today if
you go and you deposit they'll give you
100% bonus if you use promo code pomp
100 bet online go where the game starts
betonline.ag go check them out today
yeah so um let's talk about the work
part you know AI is replacing humans at
work for that you actually don't need
consumer Hardware to run these
models um except maybe in Factory
inspection or something like that where
you you have to wear a glass and you
have to identify defective items or
something of that nature where uh
something on device can help you do the
computer vision much faster and better
than a human IE can like those are
exceptional outcomes but a majority of
digital work you don't actually need uh
the large language models or like
generative models to be running on your
consumer device uh it can run on the
cloud and still fine um so what are the
constraints that are left I believe that
gp4 is already like you know 60% median
human worker today you know just a rough
number is why the 60% it's like 80% of
all tasks times 80% human
level uh it's like 80 80 by 100 time 80
by 100 is like approximately
64% uh now that 64% gets up let's say to
80% with 4.5 or five and all these
models are running on the cloud then we
already are at a moment where like we we
would need a wave if you were humans to
do the task as long as they can work
together with the AIS as co-pilot now
that's going to create new jobs but it's
going to deprecate a lot of existing
jobs so that's for the work part um now
for Consumer uh device Hardware I think
the person with the biggest edge here is
Apple uh because of their custom silicon
chips they no longer rely on Intel or
colcom to provide chips for them they've
been working on this even before large
language models was a thing uh for you
know like for augmented reality and
things like that and they're naturally
extremely well positioned to run on
device large language modeles on Apple
phones or MacBooks and we're going to
have these assistants that control the
operating systems natively um and we
we're going to first time have a new
kind of computing experience on personal
computers where that could be something
like instead of opening a computer and
seeing a desktop screen you you would
probably see like a search bar where
like tell me what to do and you know
those kind of experiences are going to
be possible for the first time it's
going to it's going to take its own
gradual progress where you're going to
start something like Apple watch one to
7 or Ultra that we have today is like
you know totally different Beast right
um so that but that's going to take its
own uh progression and you're also going
to see a lot of computing on the go like
for example you're wearing a glass like
you know this this is for uh my eyesight
but in general you can see a lot more
people wearing glasses for as a as a
thought partner while while you're
walking you want to know if you want to
buy something or not or like something
is healthy for you to eat in a
restaurant or it could be even something
that you don't have to actually ask like
when you're like in a restaurant and
you're trying to eat something and you
clearly know the AI knows it's unhealthy
for you and you've been eating unhealthy
for the last few days it's going to come
and warn you hey like you're not
supposed to eat this like you've been
eating unhealthy for the last like one
week this is not good this is the effect
it's going to have and then all these
sort of like uh surreal experiences are
going to be
possible when you think about um this
Hardware Kind of Revolution if you will
that that starts to occur it is it going
to be custombuilt Hardware or will we
still have a lot of General uh purpose
built and what I start to think about is
um the
more custom the harder it is to get into
a lot of these devices like obviously we
see Humane we see tab we you know
there's all these kind of consumer uh
Hardware that people are trying and so
what I'm wondering is like do we have to
go through a whole life cycle of product
iteration right do we have to go make
custom Hardware that's large that can
run the models Etc and then we have to
start shrinking it and basically go
right back through what the phone for
example just went through for you know
20 30 years and try to compress it in
the shortest period uh
possible I think we'll see a lot of
custom Hardware yes uh because these
models don't
need they're all like standardizing to
this one kind of computing Matrix m
multipli done really fast efficiently uh
dealing with the key value uh caching of
the memory uh and so on so I think we'll
see a lot of people trying to squeeze as
much juice out of it for inference on
the device without consuming a lot of
power
and I can definitely see a lot of people
like trying to take on Nvidia on the
inference side not on the training
side um because the inference so
there'll be some people who are going to
work at the chip ler there going to be
people work on top of that like how to
combine it together to put together an
NN consumer Hardware
device and I can see some more players
in this ecosystem outside of Nvidia too
um and of course Apple's going to keep
everything locked into and that nobody
even finds out what they're doing that's
their style so it'll be very interesting
to see different players but I'm I can
see Nvidia and some competitors helping
others to build their own devices here
too when you look across the landscape
you're very unique in that you worked I
think at open AI at Google and at Deep
Mind and now you're building perplexity
uh there are very few people who have
the diversity of experiences and The
Cutting Edge of this technology what is
something that you learned at each one
of those organizations that helped you
now go and launch
perplexity I would say a deep mind I
learned the importance of having one or
two major strike efforts of moonshots
that you know the whole companies like
ring behind to do things uh and and and
also the importance of good top down
leadership it's one of their big
strengths in fact why they perform
better than Google brain is very good
top- down
leadership uh and hiring really good
people of course they made a few
mistakes to which I also learned what
not to do there uh but the good part is
like how well they LED and executed and
uh at open AI I just learned importance
of being
relentless like they're just Relentless
they just never stop and the mentality
is just like keep going keep pushing and
um taking a more long-term view on
things like you know not overreacting to
short-term failures if if if that you
know this whole Peter thil thing if
there is a secret that you know that's
working uh and the rest of the world
doesn't believe in it it's actually a
good thing so you keep going they very
good at cultivating that because gpt1
gpt2 was all ridiculed at and like you
know people didn't really think it was a
real thing people thought it was a toy
open here was hyping it up um but open I
was internally looking at the metrics
and eval I'm like wait this really looks
like a new kind of computing like how
when have you ever seen before that AIS
can learn just from few instructions and
learn to do task even if it's not
reliable today it's going to get
reliable more with scale and and and
that raw belief in data and computing
power uh was kind of like obvious now in
hindsight but at that time it was a
secret only they believed in and the
rest of the world did not believe in i i
and and um Peter has obviously said this
before
but when when it happens in real life in
in a field that you relate to you kind
of internalize it even
more when you think of those Secrets
what are the secrets that you guys
believe you
know well what we know is the importance
of working on this a lot of people might
think okay this is like one narrow kind
of experience of AI chat Bots when I
think of AI I think of what it can do
for me not like coming and searching for
things uh or like when I think of AI I
think of Agents I don't care about chat
Bots like everybody has these opinions
but one thing we really know is whatever
AI you build it needs to be grounded in
facts about the world or else it's not
going to be very trustworthy and in
order to do that you actually need to
build a great index of the web that's
particularly suited for day-to-day
question and answering and that's a
problem that nobody's really focused on
uh and we also know that the only way of
making progress on that is to actually
go build a product at users and then
work backwards in terms of how we can
establish the flywheel and continue to
make the uh index better and better
so lot of people will write us off today
saying we can never do this Google will
obvious be able to do it better than us
but the thing they don't realize is
every single day we are making progress
like the product 3 months from now is
going to be way better than what it is
today and today it's way better than
what it was 6 months ago and they're
underestimating that uh steep curve of
like Improvement that we're going
through one person who I guess does
believe that maybe you got a shot is
Jeff Bezos uh a lot of people probably
don't know that Bezos was an angel
investor in Google you know 25 27 years
ago whatever it was um he also invested
in the latest round of perplexity how
did that come about and then it what is
the significance of somebody who
obviously saw Google made the BET was
right now saying look there's time and
opportunity for the next you know search
engine really to uh to become popular
yeah so we you know we got connected to
basos Expeditions fund that's the
vehicle through which he's investing in
companies and I believe he's also like
looking at other AI startups so
perplexity you know we we presented a
you know in the Basel style we wrote we
wrote like a small document
for for for
their for them to help write a memo for
on on us and also we gave them a
presentation and they were pretty
impressed and he approved it appr the
investment we did not I I did not
directly pitch to
Jeff uh but he did see through all the
material and approved it at the end
that's very cool and how do you think
about you know in terms of them looking
at Google and obviously having uh you
know Bel there and now looking at
perplexity well I I I'm pretty sure that
they're all aware that search is going
to change to answers using
Ai and this is like a unique moment in
time where AI is definitely going to
make life easier for people to consume
information on the web and there's
constantly going to be ever increasing
amount of information that such a tool
to exist is actually
essential and our our mission of making
the planet smarter is also like
something that appeals to them likely so
that's that's my um hunch on like you
know why they believe in us and um
whether Google succeeds at this or not
it's good for the world if perplexity
succeeds that's how I see it I'm not and
I'm not seeing perplexity success is can
be Dethrone and kill Google I I don't
want any company to be Dethrone or kill
like it's not it's not it's not a good
thing for anyone but I think it's good
for the world that in in the AI native
world of search in the AI chatbot Market
for search generic chatbot entertainment
Google shouldn't have Monopoly there
just like how it had Monopoly in the
traditional search Market that's what we
want to ensure and we want to be one of
the players to making sure it's a
competitive landscape there so I'm going
to read to you uh part of an answer that
you gave in a Baron's interview it's a
little technical for some of the
audience but I thought it'd be really
interesting for you to describe it uh
you said the real solution is to combine
the traditional search index with large
language models through a paradig called
retrieval augmented generation that's
what we built we call it an answer
engine can you explain what a retrieval
augmented generation is and then why you
believe it's this answer engine yeah
absolutely so retrieval augmented
generation means you retrieve facts from
the internet relevant to what query the
user asks first you feed that as context
to these large language
models uh which you can consider as
amazing reasoning
engines and these models look at that
context and your query together and then
synthesize an answer with citations
that's what we do now that whole process
the chatbot part of the reasoning engine
and the pulling the fact part of a
retrieval engine combined together
creates this new engine called the
answer engine that's what you're
interacting with on the front end of
perplexity it's called retrial augmented
because you're always making sure you
retrieve and then you generate so every
time you ask a qu we always look at the
web for that maybe it's not the optimal
thing to do when you're asking give me
some names for my baby boy or something
like that right but maybe that's also
like the trade-off we making with the
product in in in order to get as much
accuracy as possible for almost any
question we are giving up on the
creativity and entertainment part of the
product and that's that's this new
paradigm now now when you look at the
way people are using the product what
trends are you seeing there is it just
hey I used to go and ask the question to
Google and now I'm asking it to
perplexity I see a lot of people
tweeting saying I use it 5 10 15 20
times a day people are saying I can't
live my life without it right I mean
these are very bold powerful uh kind of
user testimonials so what are they
actually doing with the
product they can use it for anything for
example a lot of people use it for work
like they look it for look it up look up
the people they're trying to meet before
then first time in a meeting I use it a
lot during our fundraising honestly
because I really wanted to know what
were the typical
valuations um you know what what were
the typical consumer metrics that other
past legendary consumer companies
achieved at at VAR stages of their
funding cycle how many monthly active
uses they have what is the what is
retention even mean I mean the the the
story behind perplexity itself I've said
this before is like we did did not seek
to go build a search engine we built
this as a tool that we can ask questions
ourselves for and we realize it needed
to have web search grounding or else it
would hallucinate and then we had this
amazing tool and like we we gave it we
gave it access like you know to other
people and they all said okay this is
like not just a useful tool this
actually seems like an alternative to
Google so that's when we realized we had
buil something much more useful than
what we thought and we put it out to the
rest of the world now people can still
use Google for Google Maps weather
flights shopping like you know we have
not yet expanded our product surface
area to cover all of that so you cannot
just completely deprecate Google today
but there are just certain questions
that you instead of doing three or four
searches and opening tabs you can just
come to us and ask questions and and and
you get the answer in an instant versus
you get answers after like 15 20 minutes
on Google every founder when they look
at their product they see like an ugly
baby right they're like I love this
thing but there's things I want to
change there's things that you know I
just can't get over the frustration of
what are those things for you the I can
say you know first of all it's not
always having all the
information um up to date sometimes it
just see the search results and not have
enough information about something
because the index is not refreshed or up
to date yet so making an even better
index is obvious lwh hanging fruit for
us um mathemat mathematical expressions
like I'm a big I do a lot of math on the
Chrome search bar it's my different
people have different habits but that
this is my thing some people use command
spacebar on Mac and they just do it on
the Mac Spotlight so I I don't do that
and
then we are like slower than Google's
calculator um time and weather in
certain locations um I'm I follow live
sports and I I like to look at the live
scores we don't cover that today um
shopping uh we don't have all the
cataloges in the world on our index so
these are just like so easy things that
you know might seem to the user it's
like easy but for us it's actually like
prioritization uh and how to roll this
out into one single product because our
product still like retrieve and then
summarize with an llm but many of these
use cases don't need llms it needs like
accurate access to data sources but then
packaging it all together in one product
takes time and um I hope that over the
next few once we can like slowly address
all these surface areas and make
perplexity a product where you don't
actually have to leave perplexity to go
to Google you can just stay here so
that's when I think the baby will mature
into like a nice looking three or four
year old uh
kid now um hallucinations seem to be
more and more of a uh of an issue you're
talking here about a little bit of uh
data accuracy what can you do to help
people who maybe are new to using some
of these products and don't know that
huc hallucinations can be a problem
we've seen lawyers you know use this in
like legal briefs and all these stories
that have come out now how do you think
about that user experience where it it
provides aners so authoritatively but
also the user needs to make sure that
it's accurate yeah so that's actually
why we put out the sources at the top
and we also give the sources for every
sentence and we want to get the accuracy
of what sources we put at the end of
each sentence also like as accurate and
precise as possible so that we don't
link the wrong web page for the wrong
attribution
um and then we can go a step further and
say like which part of the answer we are
not very confident about and highlight
that to the end user um but we also
present other options like in case you
want to rewrite the answer with our
co-pilot which like even more to our
researcher um think about it as research
mode deeper work larger model um it's
going to get many of the inaccuracy
sorted out there so a larger or better
model and
a way of like doing the whole answering
with parsing web pages on the Fly
instead of using your index can address
like 90% of the hallucinations already
sorted out there now the remaining 10%
is still going to happen where it's
still going to say something that's not
very accurate and I think uh there are
two ways to address that one is like
shortterm try to give some measure of
confidence in your answer to the user
and longterm actually just try to like
address a long tail through Ai and
machine learning and I believe that with
sufficient scale of usage and data fly
wheels we can do the long-term thing
pretty well that's that's that's the
core bet in the
company last thing I want to talk about
is Twitter or x uh you have a sneaky
good Twitter account uh I don't think
that it is uh very um planned it seems
like you kind of just share the things
that you want to say as they come up uh
if I'm wrong correct me but um talk
about Twitter and and maybe what you
guys have used it for both uh positive
and maybe there's negatives as
well I I like Twitter I mean I'm very
grateful also to Twitter because I
remember when you know we I was drafting
the first tweets from the company
account on the day we created the
account to announce our product and I
was like man I'm going to look like a
joker everyone's going to make fun of me
here and they'll be like oh why the hell
did this guy leave his job and do this
thing uh he could have been writing
papers and now look he's making a fool
of himself 10 people are going to like
the tweet and it's it's going to look
ugly that that was the Hest fear I had
when I was drafting those tweets and
clicking the send button um but we've
benefited a lot from Twitter like
organic growth a lot of users discovered
us a lot of potential employees have
seen us on Twitter um so it's really
helped us a lot like in a world where I
mean the coreboard is called
distribution right you want to
distribute your brand your product as
much as possible you need to have
channels for that and for us Twitter has
been an incredibly good Channel
obviously my personal account is like
more raw and unfiltered than the company
account and some some of the things I'm
not very proud of what I said some of
the things I kind of like you know
played along with the crowd um that
definitely like you know how I mean you
you obviously the master of this whole
game is Elon Musk uh he he created a
whole fan fan club for Tesla and SpaceX
through Twitter and um now he's like
enjoying the benefits of it so much he
loves it so much he basically ended up
buying the product right so I I like
Twitter I think it's a cool platform
there's like negativity so a lot of
toxicity there I get a lot of comments
saying like how dare you think you're
better than Google uh how dare you
compete with them you're going to die um
you're just a rapper like like um
perplexity is going to be dead in a year
like I I get that pretty much every day
and like I think all that is keeps me
checked too so it's not it's fine yeah
well if you use it uh for positive uh
motivation then maybe it's a good thing
it's a
necessity yeah you have to I mean like
it's they're not wrong like in a
rational world like we could definitely
very much still uh be defeated and and
and I should be aware of that all the
time but the I mean again like
entrepreneurial Journeys are meant for
like those kind of Pursuits where rest
of the world thinks you're going to die
right because if your success is low
odds that's when the success is going to
be very high
magnitude I think that's a great place
for us to end arv where can we send
people to find you on Twitter or find
out more about perplexity yeah
perplexity AI is our company account
and AR Shas is my personal account
awesome and then uh the website
perplexity
doai awesome all right well thank you so
much for doing this uh I learned a lot
today I think everyone else did we'll
definitely do it again in the future
thank you Anthony